okay so i'm kind of disappointed you
clicked on this video because you're
probably procrastinating from doing
something much more important right now
but i'm just gonna go ahead and talk
about what the science says about why
our brains do this so if you're anything
like me you've probably been in a
position where you have this very very
important deadline coming up and what
you choose to do instead is delete old
contacts for your phone or scroll
instagram for two and a half hours and
just completely avoid this thing that
you know you have to do you know no one
else can do for you and you know you're
making so much more painful for yourself
in the future
and we talk a lot about this thing
called procrastination online i've done
it multiple times before but i was
actually thinking
what does it mean and why scientifically
do our brains do this because it
seemingly makes
absolutely no sense and so i went to the
literature and i read a couple of
studies on how our brains work in this
way and how they are hardwired to
actually procrastinate in the first
place and therefore what we can do to
avoid it perhaps so that's what i found
it was quite interesting i'm not going
to lie and i'm just going to get
straight into it right now there's one
study that highlights this which i
really really love in which participants
were put in this very large room and
they were asked to take a heavy bucket
of water from one end to the other this
is all they had to do but they could
pick which bucket to use either one the
bucket right next to them at the end of
the hall or number two a bucket that was
already taken halfway across the hall
and although me and you sitting here
might think well obviously run to the
half of the hall and pick up the bucket
actually they found that the huge
majority of participants would just pick
the bucket right next to them and do a
lot more heavy lifting and on the
surface this absolutely makes no sense
but the scientists have a theory as to
why our brains do this so when we're
looking at this action we might think
it's one task to take the bucket to the
end of the hall but actually our brains
see it as two separate tasks one pick up
the bucket which is fairly easy and
number two lift and carry the heavy
bucket for a distance which is a lot
more difficult and when our brains are
faced with multiple tasks they choose to
do the shortest and the easiest one
first so what our brains are doing are
thinking oh i'll just pick up the bucket
right now because this will make the
overall tasks that i have to do a lot
less now i have to do one more thing
just carry it as opposed to two so when
we are procrastinating our brains are
actually optimized completely correctly
but they're optimized for the wrong
thing our brains will always try to have
less things on our to-do list and they
don't really care about how much more
difficult our life is going to be made
in the future when i say things on our
to-do list it's literally every single
thing that our brain wants to do it
doesn't just have to be real tasks or
real jobs it can be things like oh i
really want to browse instagram or watch
a movie or reply to a text i blanked
three weeks ago which tends to be my
favorite act of procrastination
understanding that our brains are
optimized to lower the amount of tasks
that we have to do rather than lower the
overall quantity of work that we have to
do we can use this to our advantage the
best thing to do in this case is to make
our own to-do lists physical ones or
ones in our mind as opposed to just
letting our brains compute things by
themselves because as we can see
they're not really that great at doing
it when it comes to procrastination and
work in general so instead of leaving
those big and heavy tasks go to the
bottom of the list which our brains
would naturally do it's very important
to bring those up to the top and realize
nope this is the first big thing that i
have to do and there's a lot of theories
that help with this for example they'll
swallow the frog kind of productivity
theory where you do the biggest most
important task of the day first because
then you can do everything else i think
another thing that can greatly help is
also realizing that big tasks can and
should be broken into smaller ones so
instead of thinking that oh i have to
write this huge essay or oh i have to
script and film and edit this huge
youtube video it's much more easy to
kind of break it up into smaller steps
because then we are literally hacking
our brains because by breaking it up
into oh just write the title of this
video we will have this inner urge to
get that task done because now we have
more items in our to-do list and also
our brains will want to do the easy fast
ones as soon as possible because it
hates having a lot to do so one slightly
counter-intuitive way to get a huge
project done is just break it down into
as many steps as possible because then
you will literally start itching to
begin with it in some shape or form
usually the most easy thing but that's
absolutely fine this will hopefully get
your gears grinding onto getting started
and continued with the task so kind of
taking control of our to-do lists rather
than letting our subconscious go crazy
is what will help us get more things
done in the shortest amount of time if
you're into this anti-procrastination
thing i have a few videos which will be
up on screen right now overall i don't
actually think reducing procrastination
is very important but i do actually very
much enjoy the studies and the science
behind it so yep if you made it so far
thank you so much for spending this time
with me i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be kind to yourself and
others and do believe everything you
think thanks bye